dea
teame
はい風邪をひいてます
learn ワードはいセレブ
最近お金持ちや成金という意味で使われていますが英語のセレブにはそういう
ニュアンスはありません
スライヴは有名人ですですから貧しいセレブは矛盾した日本語に聞こえますが英語の
ポー餌内部はそうではないのです貧乏な有名人
そうリンジーローハンのこと
ですダウンってはい naive
日本語の内部にはセンサーや物事に感じやすいと言うには集まりますが英語のナイフに
は単純に未経験のて君があるだけで敏感というニュアンスはまったく入っていません
アメリカ人の彼氏と喧嘩している時には要注意敏感というニュアンスは全く
入っていません全く入っていません全く入っていません未経験の美経験のいい加減に
凹んじゃうや
ダウンウェアはい日本語のエゴは二項中を意味することがあります英語の良い子
テスティモそうですが英語の良い子鉄石のイージー桜の枝子はエゴではなく以後と読み
ます
エゴはアメリカの有名なワッフル会社ですキャッチフレーズおよびウェブサイトは傲慢
英語は俺の
フルを話せという意味ですへ go という言葉を耳にするとアメリカじゃあみんなを
破っ不良を思い浮かべます
マジです場合の
大エコ最近一部の人々が何もかもにエコーという言葉をつけるのを見て首を傾げざるを
えません本当に環境を第一にしたいのであれば同性指がグラまみれになりますので僕の
スパイシーチキンおい個ずつ紙で包むのはやめてみてはいかがでしょうか
a これもん
me